Mom!
*SLAPS TABLE*
Hello, welcome!
Momiplier: Hi, welcome!
Mark: Hello.
Mom: Hi, everybody!
Mark: How's it going?
Mark: Now you know how last time I, um-
...subjected you to horrors
On Reddit?
*screams of pure agony*
(oh my god poor momiplier)
Mom: yeah yeah yeah
yeah
So bad stuff (mom: very traumatic)
Traumatic
My mom has been traumatized
And she will never forgive me.
Mom: Maybe, maybe not.
Mark: Hm, maybe not.
So I've got something special for you today
that I think you're gonna like instead of hate.
This is called:
the 'Try Not to Smile... Challenge'
(Momiplier: Oh!)
Mom: Oooh, that's impossible.
Why?
Mom: I'm always smiling.
Like right now?
Momiplier: Yeh
Ok, so what we have here
is a sub reddit called
"MadeMeSmile".
(r/MadeMeSmile)
So the objective is-
We're gonna look at these things...
And we are NOT
GOING
TO SMILE
M: Give me the definition of not smiling
Smile :)
M: Smiling is showing your teeth
Smiling is any upward motion
(mark, i could think of a lot of "upward motions")
M: So as long as I don't show my teeth
It's not smiling, right?
Ok.
M: Not smiling, ok?
Ok that'll be the limiter-
So as long as we don't show our teeth...
It's not a smile
(*silently pulls up every single Markiplier Try Not To Laugh video ever made*)
You ready?
M: Yesss!
M: I'm ready!
M'kay.
3!
2!
M: Oh, I better not look at your face.
Why my face? My face-
(because it's laughable-)
M: Cause you make me smile
(oh whoops)
My face is a mask of sorrow and death.
(ah, wait, i was right-)
Mom: *giggles*
*satanic laughter*
Mom: Hmm?
M: Hm...?
M: What smiling- what-
M: what to smile about?
M: It happens everyday of life
M: I've seen it
That happened everyday of life?
Listen i-i-if I laugh at what you say,
That's very different from me smiling at what this is
M: *cracking up*
M: I'm not smiling!
No smiling!
mm-mm
M: Just everyday crap
everyday--
(dude you're not fooling anybody-)
M: everybody can do that kind of stuff
Everybody!
M: Even I can do that!
You could do that?
That's nothing
(mark you cried when you stretched for aerial silks)
Right? (M: Mm-mm)
Yeah. I believe you.
I believe you, mom.
M: Just normal everyday stuff
Normal everyday stuff. It's nothing
M: Nothing to smile about
Nothing to smile about
(Momiplier: cracks a maybe-smile? OHNO)
Oh, this is a post. Let me read it for you
*Reads above post*
M: Okay.
*laughing*
M: What's so smile about?
What's so smile about.
M: Nothing, nothing special.
Nah, that's not--
M: NEXT
(ah, got the uh, sick roasts, i see)
W-Okay, that's not nice at all.
Reading: "My daughter got a Walmart gift card for Christmas
-and she chose the new Diary of a Wimpy Kid book instead of toys."
So it's just a kid that chose a book over toys,
(crazy lil' coot, why diary of a wimpy kid?)
and apparently that's smile-worthy
M: She is... weird
*laughing*
M: She is not a kid.
M: She is a...
M: too out of ordinary
M: Nothing to smile about
Too out of ordinary, nothing to smile--
It's sad, really, it's sad (M: Yes, sad)
It's a- it's a kid not living their childhood
M: Yes. She miss the whole good childhood.
*tsk tsk tsk*
M: I feel pity for you.
*laughing*
Do you hear that? My mom feels pity for you.
This just says "Made my day".
*Reading caption*
So it's like a dad, shining his light... on the family.
M: Mmhm. :I
Anything... anything to say about that?
M: I'd rather look at you and smile
(does that count against the challenge-)
M: Mm-mm
Alright, okay
M: I have no emotion
You have n- *wheezes momentarily*
You're DEAd inside
M: V E R Y  D E A D
No heart, no soul, all gone (M: No heart no soul)
(she gave it to mark, but dark stole it)
M: As long as it's not puppies
M: And, uh, Marky, here
M-k, well I'm gonna throw a curve-ball, because here comes a puppy
This ones says "I will always love you"
*piano music in the background*
M: Heh
M: Mm-mm
No?
That's not cute?
That cute?
M: Hmm- cute but uh,
M: MmMmMMM
*mimicking* mMmMMM
M: I'm not smiling at least.
No, no, no smiling
It's stupid, actually- it's two animals fighting
Why would that be any sort of entertaining? No way
(you LIE, mark, we KNOW they get you the most)
*Reading:* "This is a portrait drawing I made for my Grandma
Unfortunately my Grandpa passed away last month so I wanted to surprise her for Christmas :)"
Oh that's nice
This kid made a portrait...
Grandpa and Grandma, Grandpa passed away
Isn't that nice?
M: Nice but I'm not smiling
No it's sad really, its sad
Why would anyone smile at this?
M: Actually it's kind of really sad
It's really sad
M: Because every time she look at that picture
M: She have terrible memory of him
That is sad
M: thats reminding every day
M: 'I don't have my husband right now'
M: He's mean
(asdf momiplier w h a t)
*laughing* he's mean
M: He's mean
That kids mean
That kid MEAN
What kinda grandchild would do that to their poor grandma
This one says 'those poor burglars'
'Macaulay Culkin'
*reads above post*
That's the kid who was in 'Home Alone'
M: Are you sure that he got the facts right?
M: There might be someone who really do rob on christmas day
You're right...
There might be sombody who really do rob on christmas day (M: yes! More gift)
Tip to all you would-be robbers out there
On christmas, there's more gifts to rob on christmas! (M: mhm)
(very word. much eloquent)
What're you doing? (M: What are you doing?)
What're you doing?
*tsk tsk*
S t u p i d.
This has just been the top of today, lets look at the top of the past month
Let's get to the really good stuff
*mumbling from momiplier*
Oh it's gonna be good, oh okay
This one's called 'the strength of humanity'
Eh? Sounds pretty impressive
*reads above post*
*SMACKS TABLE*
That's nice.
You're not smiling?
M: So sad
So sad?
M: All the trauma she have to go through
M: All those years
M: Sad
Sad
no happiness here
No joy
(wake mark up [wake him up inside])
Alright this one's 'a good father'
*reads above post*
Sounds like it cost a lot of money (M: mhm)
Sounds like it kinda offset all the work that she did
M: What was her motivation?
Well it's not her motivation it's his motivation
That's the father who wanted to be there for his daughter
M: Oh my goodness
M: I know why (why?)
M: He's using the free freq-... the mile stuff
Free frackin miles... yeah, that's it
M: That's only
That's it
Yeah, he's not spending his own money
M: mm (no way) M: He's cheap
He's cheap
*long silence as we all await the inevitable*
That father's cheap
*tsk tsk tsk tsk*
*laughter, aka the inevitable happened*
M: NEXT
'Always remember where you came from'
Oh cool it's the story of someone who came from KFC
to house-keeping to nursing, nurse and registered nurse
M: Huh, sounds like my story
You're a nurse
M: I... I did that
M: I worked as a nurse aid when i went to the nursing school
So that's nice. (M: on the weekend) That's relatable to you
M: and I become a RN (so, so this is nice?This is smile worthy?)
M: yeah
It's nice?
M: Mm-hmm
Or is it typical and everyone does this?
M: EVERYONE does that, it's not just him
M: We all do that
M: You did too!
M: oh my god, Before Markiplier, what did you do?
I wiped butts
M: Yeah (I did, I wiped- I wiped butts) yeah you did do that
M: We ALL do that
Mark: We all-- M: it's nothing to smile/smell about
Something to smell about??
M: h- No- something to- not -h
M: Nothing to smile about
Nothing to smile about
OR smell about
*Mom laughing*
*!! noise from Metal Gear*
M: (stops laughing) Mm-nn, not smiling!
No smiling-- M: I'm laughing!
Both: Not smiling!
M: I'm laughing at myself
M: Different
VERY Different, okay
M: right?
'Finally debt free!'
Credit card paid off...
Look at this!
No debt!
Isn't that good?
M: Something is fishy here...
(i mean, agreed-)
*laughs*
That is weird that it's absolutely zero on all of these
That is...
That is a little odd,
I will admit that, yeah
M: He just got a credit card, a bunch of them
M: He's happy because his balance's zero
M: ...and next month, he's gonna have a--
(through his teeth): I think you're onto something, Mother
I think you're onto something...
Mom: *clears throat to hide laughter*
Mom: I know human psychology
Mom: That was
Mom: *slaps table*
Mom: I made A all the way through psychology class
Mom: *beats table again*
(the poor table, 1 like = $1 for table's physical therapy)
Mom: hmm I know human psychology I know how they think
Mom: You know how those people think
Mark: Those people
Mom: ohhhh the credit card and
Mom: Zero Zero balance because
Mom: *SLAPS TABLE*
Mom: They haven't gone out shopping yet
Mark: *SLAPS TABLE*
(STOP ABUSING THE TABLEEE)
Mark: Hasn't gone out shopping yet
Mark: But will, after this post
Mark: So much shopping (M: Mm-hmm)
'My face physically hurts from smiling so much today,'
""I love teaching you guys" said my professor who is such a good soul"
Mom: *sniff sniff* Mm-hmm
M: What's the difference
(Mark struggles not to laugh) Mom: What do I need to smile about
M: He's smiling!
M: Why?
M: The only thing I can smile [about] is his leg is kinda funky
M: It's to the side (Mark laughs a little)
M: Just like your leg, know what I mean?
M: It TWIST!
M: Unnaturally.
M: Is that something to smile about?
(yeah, mark, is it)
Mark: No, you're right, that's not
Mark: It's a deformity
Mark: It's sad, really
Mom: Everybody's sad, feels--
Mark: Really sad, for this guy
Mark: This poor guy with his (Mom: Mm-hmm)
Mark: Messed up legs
Mark: Ok, "Same tie"
(reads above post)
Mom (while laughing): Couldn't even afford a new tie
*Mark cries in how sad it is*
M: No time for shopping
M: Excuse, excuse, excuse
M: *tsk tsk tsk*
M: And he's proud of it
M: I feel sad...
Mark: You should feel sad, yeah, it's real sad
M: Sad!
Mark: What a cheap dad.
M: Cheap dad!
Mark: Cheap. So cheap.
M: VERY....penny pinching dad
Mark: Penny pinching--That's it, yep
M: That's it (Mark: penny pinching..)
Mark: He could've bought a special tie, but he didn't.
Mom: YES!
M: It's sad, see that
Mark: It's sad, that's really sad
Mark: Very sad
Momiplier: Very manipulative, the dad.
Mark: Manipulative yup, is manipulative
Man's best friend
*reads text*
*momiplier snerks*
Mom: Whats the point, here?
Its like, the dog died when this guy was a kid (Mom: 50 years ago) yeah
and the dog's been in Heaven, or whatever, this whole time and
Mom: Dog had a better life than him
Mark: You're right (Mom: He got more spoiled)
*more enthusiastically* you're right
Mark: Its sad really *laughing quietly*
Mom: Its sad... sad. How come dog got the better life *hits table lightly*
he just came into hell... and after *hits again* 50 years
*says angrily* where you could join him early. *hits table hard* sad *hits again*
Mark: Could have died earlier *noises of agreement from momiplier*
Its sad the he didn't die sooner (Mom: Mmm yeah)
Mark: Reporting *read above*
Mom: He is really wanna be famous
somehow
give him a credit
Mom: Someday you'll be famous
with that smile
its cute too
Mark: Its sad really (Mom: really sad)
(lmao)
(Mom: Really sad) Mark: Its so sad
hes just a
fame hungry kid
(Mom: Mhm) Mark: Just trying to steal the lime life
ain't nothin' special 'bout that
Mom: Nothing special about that
Mark: Anyway... alright whats this
this is a video
*momiplier slightly weezing*
*mom chuckling softly*
*dog barks* (give me attention hoomans)
Mom: I'm laughing... I'm not smiling
Mark: I think you were smiling
Mom: No I was looking at the coach
I love that coach's... *moves hands weirdly*
reaction
I was smiling at him not the... not the one actually
*pushes up*  lifting
*dog barks* Mark: Maggie! What are you doin'
*mom laughs*
Mark: Maggie, you smilin'? Its sad really
Mom: I sad but... look at the coach
there's more... he's working harder then the boy...
than the guy in the front, you see that?
Mark: Yeaah
Mom: Thats cute
ohhh that's adorable... mhm
Mark: I think that's a smile
and I think we can end it before we
Mom: That was adorable
Mark: Crush people's dreams more
Mom: Yeah.. that was adorable
Mark: But everything else was SAD
Mom: Everything was sad
Mark: Exploitative
Mom: Yes
Mark: Full of cheap dads (Mom: They wanna be famous)
Mark: Wanna be famous
Its ridiculous
what gets on the internet these days
*mom imitates the dog*
Bubble: Yeah thats sad
Mark: You hear that Bubble?
THAT'S SAD
Mom: Mhm
Mark: I feel sad
Markimoo: Well thank you everybody so much for watching uhh...
if you smiled
down in the uhh
comments below... let us know
or
don't
cause' you didn't smile
either way
thanks Mom for being here
We've got more videos that we're going to record soon
less wholesome... more silly
but uh... you'll see soon
So thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always
we'll see you
in the next video
buh byyye
Mom: Byye
*laughing*
*Markiplier's outro music*
(this was fun staying up until 1 a.m to finish)